c'est le païen qui est maintenant en
direct avec nous à kiev cyril bonsoir on
vous a vu haïr pina l'instant vous y
étiez il ya quelques heures ou en est-on
à kiev
et bien kiev la clé c'est ie irp in
butch haus staudt mail ce sont ces
districts mais également des zones
résidentielles très peuplées qui se
trouve à 15 km de nord-ouest de là où on
voulait ce soir avec jean jacques beck
c'est à dire le centre de kiev c'est la
clé en fait du siège de kiev puis ce
qu'on sème que l'est le nord sont
totalement ou presque encerclée par les
forces russes c'est de l'entrée du de
l'ouest en fait qui se joue aujourd'hui
est d'avoir pu passer avec des
combattantes des forces spéciales aussi
ukrainienne dvd des tireurs d'élite qui
essayent de retarder l'avancé notamment
des tanks russes montre bien cette
pression militaire extrêmement
importante hier pin est une ville une
grande ville qui normalement est habitée
par des dizaines de milliers de
résidents nous avons pu voir encore et
encore ces scènes terribles dans un pays
aux portes de l'europe est bien de
famille désespérée épuisé ampleur qui
passait le dernier barrage qui en fait
c'est par la ville d'hier pin de la
partie d'hier pin qui est contrôlé par
les russes et celles où nous étions qui
est encore contrôlée par les forces
chrétiennes et puis les forces
d'autodéfense milieu ukrainienne qui
sont 1500 des gens qui viennent de tous
les métiers de toutes les générations et
qui ont décidé de rester larmes en main
donc ces flots de réfugiés qui continue
désespérément de fuir ces combats et
ensuite irvine ir pin c'est une ville
très résidentiel encore une fois où il y
a encore tous les stigmates de ce qu
était et la vie normale dans c dans
cette danse est ukraine aux portes de
l'europe développée nous avons pu
circuler avec des combattants très très
proche des premières positions russes
des tanks russes qu'on voyait à quelques
centaines de mètres à peine et il y
avait des cadavres en pleine rue que
personne et nous y est ils l'ont ne
pouvons pas aller les chercher puisqu'il
ya des tireurs d'élite des snipers
russes aussi à portée de vue donc une
situation extrêmement difficile de
pénétrer dans ces zones le district de
boudhha qui est très près de dire peiné
qui est fait aussi d'évacuer fait aussi
l'objet de tentative d'évacuation
désespérée des civils puisque les
combats vont sans doute être déclenchées
rapidement bout de chasse est déjà au
moins 70% nous disent les forces
chrétiennes qui sont qui est tenu par
les forces russes irp et nous nous
étions c'est encore 50% du côté des
russes 50% du côté ukrainien le problème
pour terminer c'est tout cela c'est
évidemment l'accès capital extrêmement
important et symbolique et stratégique
aussi à kiev où on se trouve et on est
tous le monde sait ici que les forces
russes au n'ont qu'une ambition c'est de
fonte sur cette ville et de faire le
siège de kiev qui est imminent et c'est
une question de jours on ne sait pas
mais vu l'offensive aujourd'hui vu les
explosions qu'on a pu entendre tout
autour de nous toute la journée et le
dise le niveau de destruction dire pin
qui est à 15 km de là on se trouve tout
cela ne ne présage pas du meilleur en
tout cas et donc on peut penser que le
siège va arriver assez rapidement ici à
kiev la capitale ukrainienne merci sert
il